[Music]
there are 43 quintillion possible
combinations now imagine you have no
websites no books and no one to show you
how to solve it
because you invented it but you didn't
invent the rubik's cube this guy did
my name is anaerobic was born here in
this beautiful city of Budapest it was
1974 30 year-old Erno Rubik was just
beginning his career in academia I was
lecturing design and architecture very
similar in age with the students it was
very ambitious to find new ways to teach
them especially about space and three
dimension I made a cube as a teaching
gate and for my son learn something from
it once the physical cube was put
together
ernõ began hunting for its secrets the
question was not it is possible to solve
it but the question was it is possible
to find a method to do that there is 26
small cubes it looks the same but in the
structure of the cube they have
different rules
ernõ racked his brain first strategy
twisting and turning the cube in his
hands and his head to unlock his
creation after I started to understand
the nature of this action the movement I
found a way for a solution it's not that
straight way and after a month he
cracked the code but the story doesn't
end there
I had the feeling the potential of the
object I found it very simple to
manufacture and the result of that it
can be an object what is available for
everyone in 1980 Erna would finally
bring his cube to the world and from
there it took off becoming one of the
best-selling toys of all time
because of the content of the cube the
world discovered is not a gadget it's
something that is more valuable more
long life and after almost 40 years
Rubik's Cube has seen a comeback with
hundreds of competitions every year
across the world for Erno the cube that
bears his name is more than just a toy
it's a reminder to never give up
there is always way for a solution at
all their way to find something else
something new something different or
final result of you if today is not
everything is good it's a mean tomorrow
can not be better depend on you
[Music]
a legend around this chalk is that it's
impossible to write a false theorem
I assume the special ingredients where's
angel tears mathematicians from all the
top schools very frequently is it it's a
cult favorite as soon as I use it I was
a convert the chalk is one of the
best-kept secrets in the math world it's
the rolls-royce of chalk hagoromo is a
brand of Japanese chalk the way it flows
on a board is a bit hard to describe in
words it's really hard to get only get
it from Japan you need a Japanese person
to bring it back for you I discovered it
when I went to visit the University of
Tokyo and one of the professor's there
said to me you know we have better chalk
than you do in the States and I said oh
go on chalk his chalk and so I tried it
out and I was surprised to find that he
was right I tried it I thought was
phenomenal it's the densest it erases
the cleanest that leaves the nicest line
if you use bad chalk often you've
depressed really hard for anyone to see
what you're writing
so using hagoromo on a good board it
doesn't really feel like you're working
hard to write when I'm teaching I get a
feeling of energy confidence and the
chalk absolutely helps slowly the math
world has become aware of this and it
became a bit of a fad in some circles
it was like maybe four years ago the
word came out that the company was going
out of business
I sort of jokingly referred to it as a
chalk apocalypse so I immediately
started hoarding up as much as I could i
order three boxes of hagoromo and kept
in my office and used it very sparingly
I should have bought more but I have
friends that bought boxes and boxes and
boxes of the stuff they might very well
be set for the rest of their career
without like 1506
that's a lot of days for six a day I
think I'm gonna make it I have probably
a ten year supply still at home I
calculated how many boxes what I need to
last for 10 or 15 years I didn't want to
become a chalk dealer but I did like the
idea that I could be the first stick is
free chalk dealer on the block in my
department I was probably selling it
regularly to maybe eight to ten
colleagues I would reach into my
cupboard in my office and pull out
another box and we do the deal in my
office that we all had a chalk fix and
we still do the original hygroma chalk
is slowly disappearing a few years ago a
Korean company bought their formulas and
did the best job of faithfully
reproducing and agree
there was mixed emotions I was happy to
know that it would still be made but I
was a little disappointed that I was
less clever than I thought I was
in many ways mathematics is like
craftsmanship in some ways it's like
artistry in some ways it's like science
but there's a real car aft side to
giving a beautiful lecture on a
blackboard mathematicians admire this in
each other and like to use the best
tools for it there's incredible value to
this but the value isn't using it up not
hoarding it
[Music]
so there's a direct correlation between
taste and sight you see something that
looks delicious your mouth begins to
water you see something sour you pucker
but what about sound as it turns out
sound has a direct effect on how your
food tastes oh I'm hungry
this concept is being studied by
Professor Charles Burns I'm an
experimental psychologist and a gastro
physicist the research is in two parts
part one we've found that on the one
hand people match music and instruments
and pictures of sounds to different
tastes and flavors and food and drink so
listening to a musical scale you might
say this twizzler tastes like in a note
and these pretzels taste like a G note
and part two we then play matching music
that kind of corresponds to what you're
tasting you can use that to bring out
and actually change people's experience
of sweetness of flavor in the food and
drinks that they are consuming just like
you can pair wine with cheese Spence
says that you can pair music with wine
Tchaikovsky string quartets low-pitched
sounds kind of rumbling Vitamix better
to sort of a heavy red wine to bring out
a bitterness whereas Mozart's flute
concerto it's a much better match for
certain white wines showing that we can
bring out the sweetness he actually
calls it sonic seasoning and while music
has now been proven to accentuate flavor
it can also dull it loud background
noises actually dull are salty and sweet
taste receptors think about that next
time you served peanuts and pretzels on
an airplane
souls of the sweet taste do tend to be
suppressed by that background noise the
one flavour sense however that's not
impacted umami this is savory think
tomatoes beef carrots soy when you get
on the airplane it's amazing how many
people order tomato juice and Bloody
Marys the umami taste is one that is not
suppressed by live noise like it's an
interesting concept and in the very
least the next time you go out to eat I
guarantee you'll pay just a little more
attention to the music that's playing in
the background chemistry explains
literally everything that is happening
around you the drive is taking the
thermal energy from the water
unfortunately I instantaneously get
judged on appearance that is very
frustrating for me so I'm gonna pick up
my hot water when I come over here and
I'm going to throw it right into my
bucket okay it means I have to work
harder but at the end it is so so
incredibly worth it and one
[Music]
my name is dr. Katie Bergdorf and I am a
lecturer at the University of Texas at
Austin
I'm trying to break the stigma of what a
stereotypical scientist looks like so my
thing is I am NOT wearing a bowtie I'm
not wearing suspenders I don't have some
frumpy cardigan on I'm just some regular
girl who likes to play with fire I also
really like designer shoes and that's
okay as the alginate hits the calcium
chloride the alginate would prefer to be
with the two plus charge calcium instead
of the one plus charge sodium and what
happens is we form gummy worms doesn't
matter what you look like any human can
be a scientist I definitely try to use
energy and excitement I do my best to
try to reach students that might be
intimidated by science I use anything
that will make the four hundred and
eighty three students sit up straight
and actually listen to the words coming
out of your mouth as soon as I've
exploded something in their face
I have their attention for just 60
seconds and I can do whatever I can to
shove that knowledge right into their
brains okay so what we're gonna do today
is doing some chemistry we're gonna do
three different hands-on experiments I
find chemistry to be an incredibly
challenging topic I'm so sick of the
stereotypical female scientists and we
can do things other than biology by the
way chemistry physics engineering we can
do it the fact that I've been able to
master it but then use science to start
the conversation but then physically
stand there and break that image it's
the most rewarding thing I could ever do
ever
[Music]